[Music]
thank you
what happens when we die well while
there are plenty of scientific answers
for what happens to our physical body
the question of our soul is one that's
best answered through religion hi I'm
rich Burnett for one dream and in this
episode of perspectives three experts
discuss versions of the afterlife as
found in the Holy books of Christianity
Islam and Judaism We Begin Now by
looking at Christianity's views on
eternity
oh
throughout Christianity's history
theologians and authorities have
strongly emphasized the afterlife
particularly how
many preachers and missionaries put the
fear of hell and the threat of God's
anger at the center of their theology
focusing on God's Wrath not God's love
in 1741 during the Great Awakening in
the American colonies preacher Jonathan
Edwards thundered that
wicked men deserve to be cast into hell
every unconverted man properly belongs
to hell that is his place the wrath of
God Burns against them
Dante's depiction of the nine circles of
hell in his Divine Comedy is one of the
most Vivid and enduring images in all
literature
of all the imagery associated with hell
in scripture both the Bible and Quran
the most widely used is fire
hell is described in terms of endless
burning flames and never-ending torment
The Book of Revelation says that those
who are judged unworthy will be thrown
into a lake of fire
Jesus's message came out of the Jewish
apocalyptic tradition a tradition you
can see beginning in the writings of the
ancient Hebrew prophets prophets like
Isaiah and Ezekiel told the ancient
Israelites that they had a message
straight from God this message confirmed
the final Vindication of God's chosen
people Israel at a time when God would
separate the righteous from the wicked
and the prophets warned that when that
happened there would be bloody wars the
enemies of Israel would fall and God
would signal this time with a series of
natural disasters
the New Testament picked up on these
themes for instance in three of the
gospels there is a passage known as the
little apocalypse
here the authors give an account of
Jesus's speech to his disciples two days
before his own death in this speech
Jesus tells them about the signs of the
last days he warns them of wars and
rumors of wars and he says that when his
followers have preached the gospel to
all the nations then the end will come
the earliest Christians believed that
this end time scenario would happen
within their own lifetimes and they
would live to see Jesus return to Earth
now we might ask if Christians believe
that Jesus already came and died for our
sins why does he need to show up a
second time
well the Creed approved by the Council
of nicaea in the year 325 answers this
question for us the Nicene Creed says
that Christ will come again in glory to
judge the living and the dead and that
his kingdom will have no end
so Jesus has said to be coming again as
a judge in order to bring Eternal
Justice at that time Jesus will finally
defeat the evil forces of sin embodied
in all of those beings who've rebelled
against God particularly Satan what this
means is that the atonement meaning
Christ's sacrifice for human sin through
his death on the cross that provided a
path to Salvation for humans who believe
in the Christian message
but the final victory over evil wasn't
fully realized then and there
Christ will finish the job with his
second coming
many Christians although not all
believe that the Book of Revelation
predicts some of the things that will
happen right before and after Jesus's
Second Coming Revelation paints a very
scary picture of earthquakes Rivers
Running with blood and evil leaders
coming to power there are demonic
figures like the Antichrist and the
Beast who are intent on warring against
God and His Saints so that they can
establish their own kingdom on Earth
in John's Vision this all culminates in
the battle of Armageddon when Jesus and
the Saints finally defeat these evil
Powers they also defeat Satan who has
been running the show you could say and
an angel casts him down into a pit for a
thousand years
this is a period of time known as the
millennium and the Millennium is said to
be a time of perfect peace a time when
God's kingdom will be fully realized on
Earth
at the end of that Thousand Years things
get nasty again Satan is released from
the pit and he immediately tries to
Marshal a final battle against the
righteous but God Reigns down fire on
Satan and his evil forces and you can
probably guess who wins
after this last Showdown the final
judgment comes the righteous will
glorify God forever in heaven while the
wicked will be condemned to hell
the exact nature of Heaven has been
debated throughout the history of
Christianity one point of disagreement
is whether it is a static or dynamic
experience do people grow and learn
there form relationships and engage in
activities or as Luther and Calvin
believed do they exist in a static and
ecstatic state in Blissful communion
with God
some theologians see heaven and purely
spiritual terms While others see it as
an extension of Earthly life in which
people can still enjoy the pleasures and
relationships they experienced while
alive
there has also been disagreement since
Christianity's earliest days on who can
gain admission to heaven
broadly speaking the many views on this
issue can be grouped into three
categories exclusivist
inclusivist and pluralist
exclusivists believe that only
Christians can be saved not that all
Christians are guaranteed salvation
they're merely eligible
non-christians no matter what kind of
people they are are denied paradise and
destined either for hell or annihilation
inclusivists believe that people don't
need to be Christian to be saved
anyone who is saved though is saved by
God's grace through the death and
resurrection of Jesus Christ meaning
that if you get into heaven you're saved
by Jesus whether you know it or not
pluralists in contrast see truth in many
religions
some forms of pluralism hold that no
single religion can fully grasp the
absolute truth While others see each
religion as leading to a truth that
unites them all
but in either case pluralists see people
of each religion as eligible to enter
Heaven as Believers in their own
religion
throughout Christian history and in
unprecedented High numbers in America
today Christians have believed that
non-christians can get into heaven
in a recent survey 83 percent of
Christians in Mainline Protestant
churches 79 percent of Catholics and 57
percent of Evangelical Protestants said
that many religions could lead to
eternal life
this is a dramatic increase from the
early 20th century when fewer than 10
percent of Christians were pluralists
some scholars believe that one of the
main reasons for this is the
increasingly diverse population of
America
more and more Americans have friends
neighbors colleagues even family members
of different religions which makes them
far less likely to believe that all
non-christians are destined for hell
fate of one's Eternal Soul is a central
concern in Islam and the Quran pays more
attention to judgment and the afterlife
than the Bible
The Scholar Sacha komarata and William
chidic observe
no scripture devotes as much attention
as the Quran to describing the torments
of hell and the Delights of paradise
El Akira is the Arabic term for the
after World which we might translate as
the last place
in this place there is both a heaven and
a hell
heaven or Paradise is most typically
referred to as aldana or the Garden or
some variation of that
but those who believe and do good deeds
will be given The Gardens of paradise
there they will remain never wishing to
leave
this Garden is said again and again to
be a place of lush repose
we shall admit them into Gardens graced
with flowing streams and there they will
remain forever
they will have pure spouses there and we
shall admit them into cool refreshing
shade
this description from Surah 4 is typical
over the references to the Garden which
nearly always feature water and
regularly shaded places of rest
elsewhere it's said that the garden is
replete with food and drink in abundance
honey wine and milk pomegranates dates
and grapes
the vision of paradise is unabashedly
physical a literal Garden of delights
Sora 56 provides a detailed and cohesive
view of the garden and is worth quoting
at length
on couches of well-woven cloth they will
sit facing each other
Everlasting youths will go around among
them with glasses flagons and cups of a
pure drink that causes no headache or
intoxication
there will be any fruit they choose the
meat of any bird they like and
beautiful-eyed maidens like hidden
pearls a reward for what they used to do
they will hear no Idol or sinful talk
there only clean and wholesome speech
they will dwell amid thornless loat
trees and clustered Acacia with
spreading shade constantly flowing water
abundant fruits unfailing unforbidden
with incomparable companions we have
specially created
virginal loving of matching age for
those on the right many from the past
and many from later generations
perhaps surprising to a non-muslim the
text is Unapologetic in its depiction of
sensuous reward a reward of the body
this physicality extends also to sex you
might have heard of the infamous 40 or
even 72 virgins promised to martyrs
I hate to disappoint you but there is no
such passage in the Quran
the beautiful-eyed maidens is a
translation of hurin the hurries that
are indeed said to be companions in
heaven but as we've also seen Believers
are joined by their spouses
that is while never explicit it is
assumed that sexual pleasure would be a
natural component of paradise
those who enter Paradise married will be
joined by their spouses while the
unmarried or God forbid those separated
at Judgment Day would have companions
for them virginal loving of matching age
as Christian Lang describes it in his
book Paradise and hell in Islamic
tradition
in comparison with The Culinary
pleasures and the extravagant material
riches enjoyed by the Blessed sexuality
in the quranic paradise is a rather
subdued affair
the horiz are of modest gays who comply
with what the Quran enjoins upon Pious
men and women on earth namely to lower
the Gaze and Safeguard chastity
as for married couples who enter
Paradise together the Quran delicately
Intimates Congress by noting that they
recline on couches in the shade
in other words all those things that
bring us pleasure in this world and this
life are perfected in heaven and
available for eternity
spouses are said to be made peer for one
another and divinely appointed
companions appointed for the rest bust
the rewards of Heaven be given only to
some and not others
this speaks I think to the frankness
about sexuality that is likewise a
feature of the Quran sexual Union and
enjoyment are assumed to be good and
righteous parts of life in this world
and that goodness extends to heaven
Paradise isn't simply physical
Sora 9 says God has promised the
Believers both men and women Gardens
graced with flowing streams where they
will remain good peaceful Homes and
Gardens of lasting Bliss and greatest of
all God's good pleasure that is the
Supreme Triumph
elsewhere it said that all that will
remain in the end is God's face
these and other more intangible hints
lead some interpreters to argue that the
true Joy Of Heaven is communion with the
divine
regardless the physical rewards of the
garden are Central to the quranic vision
while also serving as a Counterpoint for
the opposite
torments of hell
[Music]
in the Quran is a visceral physical
punishment
fire called amnar in Arabic is given a
specific name in the tradition
or gehenna and is referenced in some 400
different verses throughout the text
typically paired with a reference to the
Garden the fire recurs again and again
as the unambiguous place of punishment
for those who reject God's message and
commands
as recounted in Surah 88
have you heard about the overwhelming
event
some faces on that day will be downcast
toiling and weary as they enter the
blazing fire and are forced to drink
from a Boiling Spring with no food for
them except bitter dry Thorns that
neither nourish nor satisfy hunger
in many ways the fire is the inverse of
paradise suffering and work instead of
ease and Repose fire and Boiling Springs
instead of shade and Lush Springs bitter
Thorns instead of abundant fruits
just after the description of the Garden
in Surah 56 we are given an account of
its opposite
it will dwell amid scorching wind and
scalding water and the shadow of black
smoke neither cool nor refreshing
before they over-indulged in luxury and
persisted in great sin always saying
what when we are dead and have become
dust and Bones shall we then be raised
up
and our earliest forefathers too
say the earliest and latest Generations
will all be gathered on a predetermined
day and you who have gone astray and
denied the truth will eat from the
bitter tree of zakum filling your
bellies with it and drink scalding water
lapping it like thirsty camels this will
be their welcome on the day of judgment
elsewhere the peers spouses or Divine
companions are replaced with the zabania
translated as the guards of Hell who
drag the Sinners down to Hell
physicality of the torturers and how
like the physical pleasures of Heaven
are thus reliant on the literal
resurrection of the body
the rhetorical question of the
disbelievers shall we then be raised up
is evocatively Affirmed
when that Resurrection occurs is a
question of some dispute will the Damned
go immediately to the fire or will there
be a brief reprieve in the grave prior
to the yamuddin
the ultimate fate is unambiguous
the three main forms of Judaism contain
many Divergent views within themselves
Orthodox Judaism sees itself as most
devoted to tradition but is further
divided into many forms including
ultra-orthodox communities that reject
many aspects of modern life and modern
Orthodox Jews who accommodate much of
modernity while still following the laws
and ritual requirements of their
tradition
broadly speaking conservative Judaism is
less traditional than Orthodox Judaism
in matters of belief and practice and
Reform Judaism is the least tradition
bound of the three
of the three forms Orthodox Judaism is
the one that makes most frequent
reference to an afterlife although not
with anything close to the regularity of
Christianity and Islam
most practicing Jews in the west however
belong either to the conservative or
reformed movements in Judaism and it's
rare that the afterlife is a major topic
of sermons in their synagogues or Jewish
education programs
conservative and reformed Jews therefore
often don't know a lot about judaism's
treatment of the afterlife and they're
left to develop their own views on the
subject
in the Hebrew Bible God establishes a
covenant with the People Israel
in this Covenant God does not promise
that eternal life will be granted to
them
the promise is that if the people follow
God's Commandments God will grant them
descendants they're people the tribe
will flourish and they will be given the
land of Israel the sacred Center of
which will be Jerusalem
the rabbinic tradition however features
the term Olam the world to come to some
Jews these words suggest an afterlife
others interpret them as a reference to
a time when a great leader known as the
mashiach meaning Messiah but unlike the
Christian notion a fully human one will
come and establish justice and an end to
wickedness and sin in the world
Raphael author of Jewish views of the
afterlife believes that some indication
of early Israelite views on the
afterlife can be found in the Jewish
cultural custom of the family tomb
Rafael writes that the tomb was more
than a place to assemble bodies
burial in the family grave Rafael writes
served to reconnect The Departed one
with a society of previously dead
ancestors
death itself was not seen as the
cessation of existence but a passage to
another realm where departed family
spirits cohabited
Abraham upon his death in Genesis 25 8
was said to have been quote gathered to
his people
Moses's death was described in the same
way
these Patriarchs were envisioned in
death as going to where their ancestors
were some form of communal familial
afterlife
some Scholars speculate that as family
grew into tribe the family tomb concept
became a general underworld
in books of the Hebrew Bible such as
Psalms in Isaiah the place people go
after death is called shayol
no detailed description of shale is
given in the Bible but the term seems to
refer to an underworld that is a domain
beneath the Earth
sheol is described as quote a land of
thick darkness of of Shadow nethermost
pit in the deeps
there is no sense of reward or
punishment there
in the King James Bible of 1611 shayolas
translated as hell but that word gives
the idea of a punitive moral Dimension
that's absent in the Hebrew
in certain ways Shale more closely
resembles the ancient Greek realm of
Hades
it's a pale imitation of life on Earth
and one wants to avoid going there as
long as possible
a passage in Ecclesiastes reads
The Dead Know Nothing and they have no
reward there is no work or knowledge or
wisdom in shale
in the Book of Job job says
leave me a little Joy before I go to the
place of no return the land of Merc and
deep shadow where dimness and disorder
hold sway
James cars professor emeritus of history
and literature of religion at New York
University writes of shale
rather than exciting the imagination it
seems to confound it
binding one's Reflections about death to
thoughts of Vanishing into the Dust
so for the ancient Israelites death was
not a complete annihilation of life nor
did it bring reward or punishment for
one's Deeds
in a sense it was the diminishment of
life
author Johannes Peterson writes that
from the Israelites perspective quote
life is something which one possesses in
a higher or lower degree
between the first and 7th Century CE the
period when rabbinic teachings were
being compiled into the Jewish text
known as the talmud gehinom or gehenna
in Greek was conceived as an
otherworldly place where the wicked were
punished
according to the talmud however such
punishment was only temporary and served
the purpose of purging people of their
transgressions so they could atone and
partake of the world to come
by the time of the New Testament the
word gehenna was used to refer to
something similar to the current
Christian understanding of hell a place
of torment and unquenchable fire that
people are cast into
the quranic word for hell jahanam is
derived from the Hebrew gehinom
at some point the Jewish notion of a
world to come became linked with the
idea of the resurrection of the body
after death
God would establish his righteous
Kingdom on Earth and would raise the
dead so they could dwell in it
Resurrection had clearly entered Jewish
scripture and liturgy by the second
century BCE in the Book of Ezekiel God
said
I am now going to open your Graves I
mean to raise you from your Graves my
people and I shall put my spirit my
ruach in you and you will live and I
shall resettle you on your own soil
in second Maccabees a non-canonical book
for Jews written around the second
century BCE seven sons choose to die
rather than break Jewish law each
brother before he dies affirms his
belief in God and many explicitly
mention Resurrection for example the
second brother says to the king
thou indeed o most wicked man destroy us
out of this present life but the king of
the world will raise us up who die for
his laws in the resurrection of eternal
life
in the Book of Daniel thought to date to
the second century BCE a verse reads
many of those who sleep in the dust of
the Earth shall awake some to
everlasting life and some to shame and
everlasting contempt
interestingly the reward of Resurrection
for the righteous was seen as more
National than individual
Raphael writes Resurrection promised a
Revival of the Jewish people as a
community it was insufficient that
individuals would receive their reward
alone particularly in the context of a
religion that saw its relationship with
God as communal and therefore demanded
National reward
why might the belief in Resurrection to
become more widespread in the second
century BCE
this was a period in which Jews were
suffering under the Yoke of occupation
by the Hellenistic seleucid Empire and
the enforced practice of its
polytheistic religion under such
circumstances the notion of a world to
come may have provided solace
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria